earlier and this is just true of so many
of our businesses but in particular this
business
which is that our business leaders are
they are leaders in business but they're
so much more than that they're civic
leaders community leaders role models
the people who nurture and who take care
of the community
and create a warm and safe place for
folks to go
and there's nothing like going to the
barber shop
[Laughter]
to know what's really happening i always
say
to my team okay that's mine you can talk
about polls you can talk about this and
you can talk about that
what are folks in the barbershop talking
about
because that's about real talk so i want
to thank you all for the honor of having
us here today on behalf of myself and
joe biden
um gk has he did he leave already
and alma adams i want to thank um the
two incredible
not only north carolina leaders but
united states leaders yes yes
we serve together in the in the united
states congress we are
all members of the congressional black
caucus and they each of them
are powerful powerful voices not only
for the people of north carolina
but for all people in our country
someone in their absence thanked them
they greeted me earlier um councilman
cory branch i want to thank
there you are thank you for your
leadership and so many others um
so listen i wanted to be here in
raleigh in north carolina as one of the
first trips that i've taken
um now officially on the ticket as a
vice presidential nominee
because it one i love north carolina and
it's so great to come back
but two there is so much about
what happens in north carolina as a
bellwether as a measure for what's going
on in our country
both in terms of its historical
strengths but also in terms of the
challenges
the other thing we know about north
carolina is this
north carolina is a road to the white
house
there is no question about that north
carolina is a road
to reaching a majority in the united
states senate where i now serve
there's no question about that and so it
is you the leaders of north carolina
they're going to make a difference and
make a decision that is not only about
the people of this state
but the people of our nation because
with you
when you walk into that valley ballot
box and that or drop that ballot in that
box or walk into the polling station
with you
you will carry the future of so many
others
so i wanted to come here to pay my
respects but also to thank you
and to listen to you and to talk with
you because we are all in this together
we have 36 days to get it done
early voting in north carolina starts on
thursday october 15th
so there is not a minute to waste and
with that let's get started with our
conversation
thank you wonderful wonderful thank you
again senator harris we love having you
in north carolina
um so welcome to sister to sister meets
talk shop where we are engaging african
americans
under 40 in critical conversations about
the future of our communities
so for the first question up today i'd
like to uh welcome
uh john uh verdejo uh for his first
question senator harris for this brief q
a
thank you
senator thank you for thank you for
coming north carolina it's an honor
honor for you to be here thank you
um my question to you is this speaking
as an afro-latino
a black latina or puerto rican descent
latinos have been constantly overlooked
until election season how will the
bodine harris administration sure that
all are included especially the black
and brown community
that's a wonderful question and it's um
it really does highlight what's at stake
in the outcome of this election
in so many ways so let's start with
you know one of the one of the crises
that we're facing as a country which is
the coveted pandemic i think of it both
as a crisis that is about a public
health crisis i think of it as an
economic crisis and in many ways it is
about the crisis of long-standing
disparities in our country that have
been only exasperated
only highlighted which speaks to the
crisis
of systemic racism in our country so
on your point right now we are looking
at the fact that
black folks and latinos are three times
as like likely to contract this virus
and equally three times as likely and
twice as likely to die from it
and when we look at those disparities we
know that it's connected with the fact
that
there's a reflection between those
numbers and the pre-existing conditions
that existed before the virus hit
this virus is a predator in many ways
it preys on people who have pre-existing
conditions
so when you look at the latino community
when you look at the black community and
you know
that similar in many cases in terms of
the pre-existing conditions things like
high blood pressure
things like diabetes are real
and so part of the the perspective that
joe and i
share is one to acknowledge those racial
disparities
and then address them and that's about a
plan that we have for example by the way
donald trump has no plan
let's just start there so it's not even
like we're contrasting plans he actually
does not have a plan
but our plan which includes what we need
to do around
testing around treatment and i pray
every night that we get a vaccine as
soon as possible that is safe
and about distribution of that vaccine
it's about
addressing the fact that we need to grow
what barack obama and joe biden created
with the affordable care act and we need
to expand it so even more people have
coverage
that we need to deal with the expansion
in a way that we are dealing not only
with the health care from the neck down
but let us also realize we need to also
expand health care from the neck up
that's called mental health care
which particularly is an issue for us
in our latino in our black communities
especially when you look at the high
rates
of undiagnosed and untreated trauma
right i mean think about it for a moment
just step back on that point
poverty is trauma-inducing
we need to diagnose and we need to treat
it
it is it is trauma inducing that you
experience all of the effects of poverty
including violence in communities all of
these things
must be addressed and done in a in a
manner that is conscious of the
disparities based on race
based on historical disproportionate
distribution of resources
one of the biggest issues that we face
again in terms of disparities i can go
into the history north carolina knows it
better than most
but one of the issues is what is a
challenge in terms of access to capital
so the whites i'm sure they have long
stories about what they did to be smart
around acquiring capital to build up
your business
knowing that a lot of the traditional
sources of access to capital
were unavailable to black and still are
unavailable to black and brown
communities
so joe biden and i have a plan that is
about 150 billion dollars
that is going to be focused on low
interest loans and access to capital
with an emphasis on black and brown
communities knowing that our businesses
have always traditionally been again the
source of our economic life
blood and vitality so those are a couple
of things i can go into
the topic of criminal justice i think
we're going to talk about that in a
minute
um education the disparities there
you look at the fact that our children
are supposed to be learning from home
right now
but in poor communities in black and
brown communities urban communities as
well as rural communities
access to broadband is a real issue i
know it's a real issue here in north
carolina
we're talking about how our children
should be learning from home
but first of all you that requires that
you have affordable access to broadband
if you have
access at all then
if you have more than one child do you
have access to the technology
are you gonna have that many laptops so
many of our families who have access to
wi-fi it's on their cell phone a child
can't learn remotely on a cell phone
these are real issues that will have
long-term
impact on our communities if we don't
see it and address it
and that's part of the plan we have so i
appreciate your question thank you
thank you so much senator harris and
again just your answer to that being a
middle school teacher at a title one
school
definitely all the points that you have
made are definitely spot on especially
about mental health which is so
important in the african-american
community we want to turn it over now
to our next question mr lavar barnes
good evening and welcome back to north
carolina and as a proud public school
teacher in durham public schools i got a
shout out to school for creative studies
before i get in trouble
yeah um my question to you
is how will the biden harris ticket
propel young men to be able to have a
seat at the table
of leadership
all right so
first of all it requires that you see
young men
and seeing young men leaders
um you know i find myself
it was actually after the briana taylor
grand jury
decision that came down last week
i was reminded of one of the many
sayings that my
late mother had and one of them is she
would say to me kamala
don't you ever let anybody tell you who
you are
you tell them who you are
so when i say that to you i'm not
suggesting i will tell you you are a
young leader and until i
anoint you young leader you are you're
already a young leader
and i'm talking about the fact that i
recognize that and i
see that and i honor that
it means then creating not only access
but an open door with constant access
so that your role of leadership can
inform
the decisions that i make and that we
make
so that's about being not only able to
walk through the door
but having a seat at the table
on issues again like what we were
talking about around access to capital
you you are both teachers um title one
funding
joe and i have a part of our plan for
title one funding is that we will triple
title one funding and for everybody
everybody knows title one funding is
about funding that goes to
inner city schools to schools that have
the low tax base
cities that have the are schools that
have the highest rates of need
it's about what we need to do in terms
of leadership
on issues that are about education
not only k through 12 which you are both
leaders as educators
but also what we need to do around
creating access
to employment opportunities based on
providing the education that is
necessary to have those kinds of jobs
the way i think about it is we got to
stop talking just about higher education
i i like to say instead let's think
about it as
education after high school and making
sure that there are paths that are
available for education after high
school because the good jobs
most of them as we go forward are going
to require education after high school
and for some that's going to be the
ability to at some point then walk
across the stage with a diploma and a
four
year degree but for others that's going
to be getting the education so they can
get the certificate
to qualify for the job that requires
that skill
i'm gonna need your help figuring out
how we make that relevant
how we how we actually create it and as
a policy in a way it hits the streets
because a policy on high means nothing
if it doesn't hit the streets
and that's where access in terms of real
leaders who are
on the floor on the ground will make all
the difference if we're going to be
relevant
and i can go down the list of the of the
policies that
that make that so but also
it's about encouraging um
you if you're interested in running for
office
it's about being mentors i you know my
mother again i'll give you another one
of her saying she had a lot of them
but she would say to me kamala you may
be the first to do many things make sure
you're not the last
and you can look at both joe biden's
career and mine
to know that mentoring and legacy are
very much
a way of how we think about our
responsibility as leaders
so thank you for that thank you thank
you
thank you lavon for such a critical
critical question
so next as we keep this ball rolling
i'll like to introduce mr marcus bass
for the next question
senator harris welcome to north carolina
thank you for putting yourself out there
as a black woman in such a pivotal way
we see so much uh uncertainty in this
moment but one thing we are sure of is
that leadership is needed
my question the perception among many
young black and brown voters
is that a biden harris ticket may not be
reflective of a hard line on the true
reforms necessary
in our criminal justice and social
economic systems
the better than 45 message alone with
six weeks to go
needs a sharper hard line for the base
of voters
protesting in this moment right now how
will a biden harris ticket
move past the lesser of two evils
narrative being used to promote
them to young black voters and get in
tune with the issue base
of the criminal justice community i
appreciate the question
and the point so first of all
the premise of your point is something i
couldn't agree with more
which is we have to earn the votes
nobody is supposed to vote for us we
need to earn it
the other point that i think you're
raising is something that i agree
profoundly with which is let's step back
and decide how we're going to declare a
win
and how we're measuring the win how do
we define the win
because here's what i mean if you define
the win
as just simply beating donald trump
then the job is over the day we get
sworn in
but if you define the win as winning
to actually confront the issues
then the job begins the day we're sworn
in
so i couldn't agree more with the spirit
with which you make the point
now specifically on topic
i know as a former prosecutor and let me
give you the background on that
my parents met when they were active in
the civil rights movement marching and
shouting
there is not a black man i know be he a
relative or friend
who has not been the subject of some
form of racial profiling
unreasonable stop or excessive force
i grew up understanding how the system
works and it was the very distrust
that so many have today that propel me
to become a prosecutor
because i decided well there are many
ways to deal with the system
i'm going to choose to go in the system
to see if i can't help reform it from
the inside
which is why i created some of the first
in the nation initiative
for example one that focused on young
men who were arrested for drug sales and
getting them jobs and counseling it
became a national model
so i'm committed to this this is part of
my life's work
joe and i are very specific about what
we will do
as a start ban choke holes and carotid
holes
george floyd will be alive today if they
had been banned
we will create a national policy for a
standard for use of force
what's that about well excessive force
right now when it happens in many
jurisdictions the question to ask is
was that useful force reasonable
well as we all know you could reason
away just about anything
the more fair and just question to ask
is was that use of force
necessary joe and i
also have a plan to have a national
registry
around police officers who have broken
the law why
because in many places where there has
been excessive force as an example
because the burden to prove it see the
earlier point i made
is so high sometimes those cases just go
by administrative process
so there's an administrative process and
the person gets fired
well there's nothing that then follows
that person when they move to a
different jurisdiction
and go get hired there so we're talking
about a national registry
we intend to get rid of the federal
death penalty
to decriminalize marijuana and expunge
people's records who have been convicted
and to get rid of the private prisons
why is that important
because let's be